philippe s'est bâtie dans l'oreillette
c'était de bouffier de boucler ce faire
une interview je tenais debout je fais
plus petits allez on y va
c'est parti à des questions ils ont dit
quoi tes parents quand tu leur as
annoncé que tu voulais faire du patinage
artistique c'est pas grave on t'aimera
comme c'est pas grave on t'aimera quand
même c'est quoi la plus grande fierté de
ta carrière je vais faire re cause cette
fois dit comme personnage mais
entretiennent la glace
donc je vais faire rocco siffredi mais
celui qui entretient la glace n'est pas
dacquois si tu n'avais pas été patineurs
qui aurait fait quel métier d'acteur
porno j'adore les sports de glisse
acteur porno parce que j'adore les
sports de glisse
[Rires]
si je te dis on vient d'en parler il ya
un sens si je te dis nelson monfort tu
me dis ne me parle plus de ce connard ne
parle plus de ce canard mais ça a été
dur avec eux avec lui il a baisé ma
femme je peux en parler
il a baisé ma femme se plaint pas c'est
quoi ton sucré beauté pour paraître
toujours aussi jeune la glace ça
conserve
ah c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'elle est on
plus gros défaut une grande gueule et
une petite [ __ ] tom a une grande gueule
et une petite [ __ ] us c'est quoi le
grand fantasme et sur le plateau ne me
dis pas c'est clair non
sétif a dit non non plus gbagbo sait
qu'il hisse et magloire web
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chaud c'est chaud et ses
chaussures -elle j'ai bien kiffé a
changé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]